[Música]
soy alex massa y soy parte de una
familia homoparental una familia
homoparental es una familia como la tuya
pero en este caso somos dos papás y
nuestra hija
desde niño siempre soñé
casarme tener una familia tener una
carrera exitosa
todas las cosas que la sociedad me decía
que no podía tener por ser gay
sin embargo lo logré
pero este no era el reto más grande al
que me enfrentaría en mi vida
este lo conocería después
nunca me había tocado vivir
discriminación
cuando estamos llegando a monterrey en
búsqueda de un colegio para nuestra hija
encontramos una escuela que se acomode a
nuestras necesidades
transcurre una semana
todo fluía perfecto recibí una llamada
de dirección con sentido de urgencia
a la cual me descuadre por completo
sentí que el corazón se me destruyó
y sobre todo sabía que era sobre un tema
de nuestra familia llegue de inmediato
cuando pude
directo con la directora
esta me estaba esperando con una mirada
de desapruebo total
a lo que me pregunta
sabes por qué estás aquí verdad
y después en ese momento fue no no sé
pero dime
su discurso comenzó de la siguiente
manera
a mí me encantan los programas modern
family the new normal
con temática homoparental y todos los
programas que mencionaba
sin embargo creo que esta institución
monterrey y el país no está preparado
para una familia como la tuya
pocas veces me quedo sin palabras en mi
día a día este momento fue uno de esos
ella continuó explicando que a la
escuela iban tíos padrinos que realmente
no daban a conocer más de sus vidas pero
eran parte de una familia no decía
incluso que había familias naturales de
papá y mamá que cada quien hacia su vida
separados y que probablemente lelagain y
ella llevaba su vida aparte pero a la
escuela llegaban como una familia
obviamente yo no podía aceptar de
ninguna manera darle un ejemplo a
nuestra hija basado en mentiras sobre
todo después de todo lo que hemos
logrado
ella se ofreció a redactar una carta
donde abogaba por nosotros ante los
dueños
para obtener la permanencia de alejandro
en esa escuela alejandra nuestra hija
la carta era
completamente discriminatoria
pero sobre todo ofensiva para nosotros
en el aspecto que declaraba los
siguientes puntos no podíamos
presentarlos los dos a la escuela al
mismo tiempo no podíamos conocer a
ninguno de los padres o madres de
familia no podíamos participar en ningún
evento escolar ni en ningún festival
pero sobre todo nos pedía que nos
disculpamos por todos los inconvenientes
que nosotros estábamos causando a ellos
donde salí de esa reunión completamente
devastado
con un sentir de querer dormir toda la
tarde y no saber de nada
llegó a casa le cuento a mi marido lo
que había sucedido
y dejamos que todo pasará dijimos
probablemente esto a lo mejor es el
shock de lo nuevo y va a pasar
transcurrieron tres semanas en lo que
recibimos otra llamada de la directora
en esta vez me pedía que yo fuera a
presentarme directamente con ella
llegó el día
un día muy duro donde sentíamos mucha
ansiedad
nos presentamos ni siquiera habíamos
entrado al plantel cuando dos guardias
de seguridad nos estaban esperando y no
nada más eso estaba la recepcionista con
la caja de útiles escolares de alejandra
entrada entramos a la parte de antes de
la puerta y nos avientan los útiles
escolares al suelo esta parte fue lo que
más me devastó sobre todo porque nos
trataron como criminales impidiendo la
entrada a la escuela en ella en ese
momento nos dicen alejandro queda
oficialmente expulsada de la escuela en
este momento nosotros empezamos a
preguntar cuál era la razón por qué
estaba sucediendo a esto inmediatamente
mi cuerpo reaccionó y empecé a vomitar
ahí
aproximadamente como por 15 minutos
entonces fue como una reacción de mi
cuerpo a una situación muy desagradable
salimos
obviamente hicimos lo que teníamos que
hacer contactamos organismos de defensa
de derechos humanos a la secretaría de
educación pública a profeco incluso por
todo el tema de los pagos que se habían
hecho
medios de televisión de comunicación
el caso
se convirtió viral
las notas tomaron relevancia no sólo
local sino nacional e internacionalmente
y fue ahí donde nos dimos cuenta que la
mayor herramienta para visibilizar a las
familias
era estar en todos estos medios de
televisión y que la gente se diera
cuenta que realmente existimos y no
invisibilizarnos y no hacer nada al
respecto sino todo lo contrario
estar ahí estar afuera y estar visible
después de esto
sabíamos que no iba a parar ahí y que
necesitábamos lograr hacer algo más algo
fundamental algo que generará un impacto
en la sociedad como nosotros lo
estábamos buscando sobre todo algo que
generará un mejor futuro para nuestros
hijos un futuro más incluyente un futuro
sin prejuicios pero sobre todo diverso
es así como nace esta increíble
herramienta mi familia como la tuya mi
familia como la tuya es un cuento para
niños quienes suele el futuro en nuestra
sociedad
explica los diferentes modelos de
familia que existen en nuestra sociedad
un cuento incluyente un cuento diverso
pero sobre todo hecho
la ilusión de poder cambiar al mundo
este cuento significa mucho para
nosotros
como padres pero sobre todo como
ciudadanos queriendo buscar este impacto
social de aceptación diversidad e
inclusión
después de que lanzamos este cuento
es el que es el legado más grande que le
podíamos dejar nuestra hija nos dimos
cuenta que no era solo es el mensaje el
mensaje fundamental de este cuento es
mostrar que todas las familias todos los
diferentes modelos de familia
el común denominador que tienen es el
amor
y eso hace que mi familia sea como la
tuya gracias
[Aplausos]